the red sox starting pitcher nick
pavetta 5-0 with 359 era yeah still
undefeated not that good last time out
against toronto and no decision but this
is his 13th start career against atlanta
five and two lifetime he brings the o2
and he does that was good morning good
afternoon good night from mr pavetta
what a way to start it's a one-out walk
to freddie freeman and that brings ozzie
all these to the plate
smoked into right center field that's
gonna get down for a base hit that's
gonna go up against the wall renfro
couldn't get it freeman on his way to
third they're gonna wave him around here
comes the relay throw freddy's chugging
to the plate he's gonna slide in ahead
of the throw
freddy freeman scores from first and
ozzy all the way around to third and the
braves strike first in the first that is
the 200th extra base hit for aussie
albies it comes in the first inning in
boston two down runner third base for
dansby swanson
driven toward right that's well hit long
run renfro can't get it that ball is
down a run is in dansby on his way to
second he's gonna throw out an anchor
and swanson comes through with a two
strike two out hit and atlanta leads it
two to nothing sandoval with his three
hits last night up to 286
and popped up
twisting into foul ground divers racing
over near there dugout he's got room and
he makes the play right on the railing
but two runs in as the braves strike
immediately drew smiley has a
two-nothing advantage
and he's been excellent jeff as you see
over his last three starts all three of
them quality outings for the braves yeah
you saw that first four starts what does
that have in common with an adra nine
home runs allowed as you said his last
three starts you see that only two home
runs
on the ground to third riley's got it
perfectly placed and there's out number
one smiley delivers to verdugo the 2-2
is right back where it came from oh what
a play by dansby to rob verdugo overhead
wow great play one hop
plenty of time throw the strike to
freddie and that's one reason even when
dames was struggling early in the year
hitting you knew he was gonna snit was
gonna stick with him defensively does a
great job at shortstop
already swings at the first pitch of the
second inning and hammers one into the
left field corner
and heredia is on his way to second with
a stand-up double after a 27 pitch first
inning for nick pavetta he's in
immediate trouble runner to third one
away now you give contreras a chance to
get a guy in
he did put it in the air toward left and
playable for verdugo on the warning
track there's the catch runner tags and
atlanta takes a three nothing lead abc
baseball to perfection for the braves
more trouble on the way in ozzie albies
who tripled and scored a run in the
first inning he has an rbi already has a
chance for a couple more
and put him away so he gets out of it
any further damage there with the
strikeout but another run in three
nothing atlanta as hunter info the sixth
batter will hit next
this one is slug down the line hooked
into the corner and that ball's gone
conor renpro gets the red sox on the
board his sixth home run
and that did not take long
to get up into the monster seats nick
you mentioned this guy will give up the
home run yeah home run under 12 that
smiley's given up a little curveball
that got out of the ballpark in a hurry
renfro home run number six so now he
starts his second trip through the order
and [ __ ] hernandez is the batter
he did and it's right back to the mound
a comebacker
and smiley
fields his position hernandez hits a
bullet but he's out of luck and so are
the red sox to the fourth we go
to base runner with debra's coming up
he's over one
slammed into center field and ciarte
will watch it fly it's gone a two run
homer
rafael devers just destroyed one dead
center field
to tie up the ball game another hanging
breaking ball by smiley little curveball
and i'll tell you what devers hit a golf
ball right out of here that ball took
off i mean like a
jet propeller halfway out
that'll bring up riley who has struck
out and walked swing and a rope hit
toward left that's into the monster
seats
so the third baseman each have a homer
tonight austin reilly just broke the tie
number 10 for the braves third baseman
and his seventh homer in the last 17
games there's smiley back to work with
the lower portion of the red sox order
here's a swing and a miss takes care of
dahlbach who's all for two
to vasquez and he chased that ball to
the dirt nice stop by contreras
that was a nice fundamentally sound play
by the braves catchers radio 296 with a
pair of home runs
and he's going to sit down that is
strike three caught looking number 97
here
and down he goes hacking back-to-back
strikeouts vivetta getting the first two
with the k let it go
oh yes he did his ninth k in the book
tonight he strikes out the side here in
the sixth so a couple of base runners
for xander bogarts who's flied out he's
also walked and scored
a little serve to third base here comes
the throw to the plate and he is safe oh
beautiful
diving in and he has tied the ball game
what a jump off third base by madugo
they're going on contact there's no
question about that and he got a great
jump he had to to beat that ball so here
is darius with a chance to put the red
sox ahead for the first time tonight
here's the 0-1 swing there's a drive
line down the left-field line if it
stays fair big trouble it's a fair ball
off the wall jd scores bogarts to third
he is hell there by carlos fables a wall
ball double for raffi he's the american
league rbi leader now with number 43 and
he gives the red sox a 5-4 lead
jax is 3-2
and that is ball four so he will take
the free pass and it was close but
they're all filled up for vasquez he is
overdue for a big hit
he'll line that one into the right
center field bogarts is in to score
debra's right behind him
santana hits third and stops there
vazquez comes through indeed gigantic
hit for vasquez got another fastball and
he put that right center field stroke on
him so two more runners in scoring
position for the red sox
royal for two and the reigns really
starting to come down now in boston and
a swing and a miss and that will retire
the side but a walk in a two-run single
puts boston in front we are getting
ready to resume play after almost three
hours gentlemen of a rain delay here's
danny santana and now as a pinch hitter
walked in the sixth inning
hot shot and that one will roll behind
swanson a run is in
bogarts will score renfro moves up 90
feet and the red sox lead it eight to
four first and third and still only one
man out
fly that one will slice into right acuna
moves over to make the catch
tagging up and in to score is ren pro
and the red sox lead at nine to four rbi
number three tonight for vasquez one on
for william contreras as this ball is
crushed toward left field
that is into the night sky and that is
into the light towers a mammoth home run
for contreras
who's
picked up a two rbi night talk about
light tower power wow down to lansdowne
street when he hit it i i knew obviously
it was hammered the way contreras sat
there for saying i thought it was foul i
did too so barnes inn with a runner on
at first base in one down
hammered
devers bogarts onto first and a red sox
turned two
to win the ball game 9-5
the final score